j'ai débloqué développé des techniques
de combat
[Rires]
qui sont entre le tutu brésilien le Krav
Maga et le paddle
qu'on fasse
[Applaudissements]
merci
c'est très simple je vais vous montrer
différentes techniques et différentes
possibilités d'attaque de reins
c'est très simple pour chaque
possibilité je vous montrerai quelle est
la technique de combat d'accord oui pour
cette première
phase et cette première mise en
situation je vais demander à celle qui
connaît le mieux les boîtes de nuit de
venir au centre de la piste Daniel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et là vous êtes un petit peu plus loin
en train de boire un verre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en train de chiner en train de chiner ma
meuf là le rat est certainement frère
récalcitrant tu viens me dire qui est
embêté
alors là je te déséquilibre et la voilà
et là
et là non c'est bon alors je voudrais
voir qui est dans le rap non
[Applaudissements]
ta gueule
moi je peux pas continuer comme ça
non mais j'arrête cette séquence déjà je
t'explique tu vas voir une prime que
jamais personne n'a eu dans cette boîte
merci c'est gentil
ça me touche
de faire des stages
au niveau psychologique
19 ans tu avais avant ce stage la vie
devant toi c'est Daniel parce qu'il y a
une caméra
[Rires]
c'est très bien ce que je pense d'elle
c'est très bien ce qu'elle a fait ce
weekend
[Applaudissements]
quel est ton prénom Zakaria je peux
t'appeler Zaki
le président de
[Applaudissements]
Paris au bureau tu es dans les locaux
d'âge de zoo question tout le monde se
pose Mathieu déjà vu non
si deux fois à côté de l'ascenseur
c'est tout
tu sais que tu mets en péril mon avenir
si vous vois tous les jours
[Applaudissements]
celui à qui tue encore référence
[Rires]
ique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez quand deux race se retrouve
on ne sait pas quel est le plus grand